a former shale gas fracking site in
little plumpton in lancashire the
community here dismayed that the
government is due to lift a ban on
drilling
chris and susan holliday live close by
and have fought fracking every step of
the way well it does feel like they've
done this on a whim we were that close
to
the site being closed down and restored
and now it seems to
everything's up for grabs again
i'm astounded because the moratorium was
put in place in 2019 because of the
earthquakes the government have always
said that it'll stay in place unless the
science changes as far as i'm aware
there's nothing being
published to say that the science has
changed sections of a leaked government
commissioned report from the british
geological survey appear to say just
that
but the same report also points out that
other industries are allowed to cause
more seismic activity than fracking ever
was and suggests more consistent
standards
it's what fracking companies have been
lobbying for
if you apply the regulations that you
apply to shale gas to the construction
geothermal quarrying or coal mining
industry none of them would be able to
operate in the uk
looser regulations are what activists
like nick danby fear we're in the grip
of a climate crisis and to even be
considering launching a brand new fossil
fuel industry is just absolutely absurd
it makes no sense whatsoever given that
this government is is committed to net
zero by 2050.
the new prime minister disagrees
this is about much more than just
fracking for gas here in lancashire this
trust has said her government is
preparing to grant around 100 new
licenses for oil and gas drilling in the
north sea in essence she is ushering in
a new era of fossil fuel exploration and
extraction here in the uk
it's good news for an industry already
enjoying record profits
although the government says cheap
renewables are also part of the answer
critics say the uk is going backwards
searching for more oil and gas when it
should be doing more to stop using them
all together hannah thomas peter sky
news